I only played the video game just like a
little bit I don't know if you guys
really played the video game they tried
to stay true to the video game because I
saw a little thing about the making and
I was like oh that's cool they're trying
to like be true to the people who are
out there like oh yeah we we know that
no it looks just like the video game I
didn't like the pilot as much as I liked
the second episode because a lot of
times in a pilot they gotta explain
what's going on this is what this is
about these are the characters this is
the world and they did like in they did
an okay job Pedro Pascal that I love
this dude I believe him anything he's in
and the girl's doing a good job too
Bella Ramsey like I wish the budget was
bigger it does look great like you the
clear CGI so anytime you see that you're
like okay I believe this but sometimes I
feel a little iffy about like when they
go inside and this is clearly a set now
I don't know if they did the best job of
that stuff so I think it's a great show
like I'm invested like I want to watch
till the end like I'm not I'm not gonna
check out on this show as of right now
it's gonna get like seven woo-woos
[Music]